- 'Cause once you give up,
you're just waiting to die.
You know you want nice, quiet,
stay at home with grandma,
pour another glass of water,
put her false teeth in it.
If that way one and one can equal three.
That it doesn't matter who you are,
your dreams can come true.
Everybody's in one business.
The people business.
It says music business.
It doesn't just say music.
Give me a new maze every day.
My most profitable
venture is Gene Simmons.
I want it.
I want it...I want it all.
We all have our crosses to bear,
so (bleep) what, get over it.
- He's a rock star, singer,
songwriter, entrepreneur,
and television personality.
- He was known as the demon
and the co-lead singer of KISS.
- He has an estimated net worth
of over 300 million dollars.
- He's Gene Simmons and here are
his top ten rules for success.
- Because you want inspiration,
look to your mother.
You bet.
Don't listen to the self help
gurus and the people stuff,
even though I get paid a lot of
money to do this stuff myself,
(audience laughs)
turn around and look at your mom.
That's the most inspiration,
that's the reason you should
go out there and strive.
I remember the first $10
million check I ever made,
and it came in a one
lump $10 million check
and I gave it to my mother
and I said mom, look,
because you know I want
my mom to be really proud
and she said in her broken English,
hold on a second,
and she said in her broken English
wonderful
cause you know she's Hungarian,
wonderful (speaks in foreign
language) it's Greek.
Wonderful, now what are you going to do?
(audience laughs)
That's precisely the point.
You did well, now go on.
If you're the fastest human
being on the face of the planet,
when all the cameras leave,
and the girls stop kissing you,
and you put the award away,
are you going to get up
the next morning, when the
sun is just coming up and
all by yourself, try to
break your own record
even though you're the fastest on earth?
The idea is shouldn't
life be about striving.
There is no such a thing as winning.
There's only doing better
than you did before.
'Cause once you give up,
you're just waiting to die.
Staying power means hard work.
Staying power means everyday you get up,
and you try to stay ahead of the pack.
Sort of march to the
beat of your own drummer,
this notion that music
becomes homogenized,
in other words, there are
lots of successful rappers
that have short careers,
because if you can replace
one rapper for another
you're done.
The more unique you are in what you do,
the better your chances of continuing on.
So when you take a look at
me, sometimes its musical.
Take a look at a band like AC/DC,
you hear it, you
immediately know what it is.
That's what they serve up.
You want ballads, go to another band.
They serve up straight up.
That's what you do.
KISS serves up spectacle.
We will not sit around on stage
on a Persian carpet, light the candles,
and sing about
♫ Oh the flaxen haired lass
♫ On the English countryside
kill me now!
We don't do that.
You want nice quiet stay
at home with grandma,
pour another glass of water,
and put her false teeth in it,
let the spinach rise to the top,
that ain't what we do.
We blow stuff up.
With a drummer and a back beat.
And don't sing about the secret of life
'cause there is none.
Here's the secret of life,
you're alive and then you're not.
That's it, that's the secret.
Be glad you're alive while
you're alive you're allowed to
shake the world up a little bit.
And that's what you do.
Rockers are on of the
most important assets
not detriments, assets,
partner up with somebody who
knows something you don't.
In that way, one and one can equal three.
Hang out with smarter or better looking
or more successful people than you are.
They'll take you up.
- You think Paul Stanley's
better looking than you?
- Paul Stanley's a much
better looking guy than I am.
Much more creative,
and knows things I will never know.
And likewise from myself
in regards to him.
One and one equals three.
We've been together over 40 years
and where we sit now,
KISS outsells the Beatles and Elvis,
we have more licensing
and merchandising products
than almost any band out there,
which is to say, we have a
KISS golf course in Las Vegas,
and we're going on a KISS
cruise in about a week.
When I first came to America,
of course I couldn't speak any English,
and I went to see Pinocchio.
I thought the music was great,
and this little puppet boy,
I immediately connected
to this Pinocchio kid.
All of sudden, this little cricket,
this Jiminy Cricket character
comes in like the Messiah,
and looks at the movie
screen and starts singing,
When You Wish Upon A Star,
♫ Your dreams come true
I thought he was singing to me.
Shhh Gene, this is from me to you.
And I could understand the words enough
that it doesn't matter who you are,
your dreams can come true.
- You know, what's right to create for
in the sense of the merchandising world?
How do you know what's going
to work and what's not?
Where the success...
- You don't, you don't.
You learn to listen.
People will tell you what they like
which is why, there's an interesting
example of what I'm talking about.
Steven Spielberg, who I've
met, listened to obviously,
is the most successful
filmmaker of all time.
He makes every single one of his movies
has made at least $100 million.
Without fail.
Nobody has equaled that record.
And he's done everything from
Jewish concentration camp stories to
aliens from other worlds
to Color Purple to all kinds of stuff.
Every single one made $100 million north.
What he does is, he makes a movie his way,
he's also part owner of Dreamworks.
Nobody's going to tell him what to do,
how to think, how to edit.
But he does a strange thing,
after he gets his movie
exactly the way he wants it,
he will take his movie and
go to Ypsilanti, Michigan
and he'll sit down with people
who are completely unqualified
pretty much to do anything,
especially to tell him
how to edit his movie,
and he will listen to them with
what's wrong with his movie.
They'll say I didn't like the ending,
I don't like that person,
I don't like that actor.
And then he goes back and he changes it.
He listens to the most unqualified people
because ultimately you,
PBS, KISS, every body
is in one business.
The people business.
And no matter what we think of them,
whether they're the great American
populist or the unwashed masses,
you can make any point
of reference you like,
they're the bosses, we just work here.
This history of KISS, pretty much
started like any other band.
Four knuckleheads off
the streets of New York
who had big dreams of becoming,
sort of the American version of
The Beatles on steroids.
I was always trained as a
young child to go to school
and to learn and to read voraciously,
even subjects I wasn't interested in.
So when we first started
putting the band together
I read Billboard magazine,
a Record World, a Cashbox,
the weekly bibles of
the business of music.
And if you believe in full
disclosure in advertising,
it says so right away, it says
music business.
It doesn't just say music,
so I recognized that it was
a business and I was curious.
How does it work?
What's the price of goods?
Where's the profit margin?
What's the distribution method?
Who, what, when, where and how.
My mother continues to be
the greatest inspiration
which is if you take away all your stuff
could you do it again
in a different field?
So, I'm in a band, and I
have a restaurant chain,
called Rock and Brews which
is in Los Angeles, and
Nashville, Kansas City, Maui,
Cabo, every it's exploding,
and I own a football team,
the only one in Los
Angeles called LA KISS,
we're on CBS Sports,
ESPN, and all that stuff.
Branding, licensing, merchandising,
KISS is celebrating our 40th anniversary,
(applause)
and boy do I look good.
We continue to tour the world.
I leave Friday from New
York and go to Mexico City
where we're going to be
playing the stadium there.
The day after, I go to Phoenix to continue
with Me, Inc promotions stuff
then hop on to the Bahamas
for the KISS cruise
where 4,000 or 5,000
crazy KISS fans pay about
five grand a piece.
Let me see, that's $20 to $25
million gross, we take 70%.
(chuckles)
And then I go into a Vegas residency,
in other words, the band
would be enough for anybody.
I'm voracious, that's a
big word like gymnasium,
I want to read everything, I want to learn
stuff I don't know because
the mouse when it first starts
to learn how the maze works
is alive, 'cause you don't
know where you're going
and it's the hunt not the kill,
and that's a killer mouse that's
going to finally gets to the cheese.
Now unless that maze continues to change,
that mouse is going to take its time
and get fat bloated and lazy
and finally get to the cheese
because it knows where it's going.
Give me a new maze everyday,
I don't want to get,
I don't want to lose my
killer instinct, you know.
So every day, as far as I'm concerned,
should be a new Me, Inc,
new Me Incorporated,
because I am the business.
- [Male] What would you say your most
profitable venture is right now?
- My most profitable
venture is Gene Simmons.
- Investing in yourself.
- Yes.
Know your product well, they say.
I invest in myself.
I never use capital to
invest in other areas.
I mean, I'm in the stock market and so on,
but I'm very conservative.
But with myself?
Anything I'm passionate about,
I'll throw capital at and
any new venture I'm involved
in, I'm totally committed
to, because I know I
never look at the clock.
- How do you juggle the acting
and the musical careers?
Which takes precedent?
- I don't think...
I take precedent.
Whether it's now or later,
there's time to do everything.
A lot of people don't
understand it, but that's okay.
Because other people don't have...
They have limited visions, limited dreams.
People sometimes only want
to be a successful doctor,
that's all I want to be doctor.
Well I want...I want it, I want it all.
- You went to school
in South Williamsburg.
Have you been back recently?
- Oh I did worse than school
there, I went to yeshiva.
(audience laughs)
I was a hasidic Jew.
You know ha-see-dem but
I don't believe 'em.
(chuckles)
Yeah, I know I don't look
like I come from Sweden,
but when I first came to America,
my mother wisely wanted
to keep me off the streets
because in Williamsburg there
was the Williamsburg Dragons
and it was a street gang made up of guys
and I'd never heard of
Christ or anything like that
and I started in broken English and stuff.
At night if I stayed out
there longer than 10 pm
I'd hear Christ-killer,
never heard of Christ, didn't know
who what they were talking about
but they were coming after me.
You know, trying to do some harm
just because of my religious beliefs.
You know, I was a Jew.
It wasn't popular then,
still not a popular thing.
But by the way, it's not
popular to be a woman.
Everybody picks on you.
It's not popular to be black, Hispanic,
we all have our crosses to bear.
So (bleep) what?
Get over it.
Cry over there.
There's a puddle of water,
every body takes their turn
to say I was a (mumbles)
and every body picked on me.
You're right!
The world is an unfair place.
It's prejudiced, it's biased.
He will think, I'm a Jew.
He's gay.
(bleep) all of you, okay?
(laughs)
Get over it.
Of course it's tough when
you're black, gay, Jewish,
you know, like a lot of stuff.
Then you got a lot of stuff
and you can get over that too.
(audience laughs)
Everybody's got their stuff,
at least America gives you a shot.
In this biased, racist world,
we have an African-American president.
So you can do anythi...
We may even have a female
president next time.
So, cry to your mommy, I
don't really give a (bleep).
Just get out there and
you know the military's
got a great phrase.
Shame on you if you don't get
up and be all that you can be.
Can you imagine if you don't
live up to your potential?
And I guarantee you that
there's greater greatness in you
than you ever imagined,
'cause once upon a time,
when you were a little child,
did you ever, I'm making it up,
you're making $100 grand a year,
did you ever envision more than that?
Okay, $300...
$100 million a day, I don't know.
But could you ever imagine,
when you were a kid?
You couldn't imagine.
If I found a dollar on
the floor, so perception
of wealth, and how you're doing in life,
is all based on where you are
and what you can perceive.
And I'm telling you that the
future can be so much bigger
and so much greater for you.
- Thank you so much for watching us.
We made this video because
partner office asked us to.
If there's someone you'd
like us to profile next
please let us know in the comments below
and we'll see what we can do.
- We'd also love to know
which one of Gene Simmons'
Top Ten Rules meant the most to you.
Leave it in the comments below and
we'll join the discussion.
- Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe,
and we'll see you soon.